miss dalton it is common knowledge you
have been cast into this world without
fortune or prospects it is my desire to
have you as my wife i am greatly
honoured by your offer but i cannot
accept this offer will not be extended a
second time third actually out of my way
idiot peace
[Music]
my dearest selena will you come visit me
in london i promise you will be well
entertained
i need your assistance there is a
gentleman mr malcolm he humiliated me
no
i then found out he had a list
you have a list of qualifications for
pride i would love for mr malcolm to
receive the comeuppance he deserves
plus it could be rather fun
if we present you as the perfect woman
then he discovers he does not meet the
requirements on your list that would be
a perfect sort of poetic justice
[Music]
mr malcolm there's someone i want to
introduce you to miss celina dalton i'm
very pleased to make your acquaintance
perhaps you might join me for a tour of
the picture gallery
most certainly have a reputation is that
the famous mr malcolm do you know him
and you believe this description of me
he was very impressed by her written
humor i must be near-sighted may i
assist selena it is working
why did you come to london with stalking
because i was lonely i was lonely too
before you came
your list is a shield you do not want to
give your heart to a woman unworthy
it gives us hope and hope is a good
thing perhaps i am mistaken and thinking
hope a useless thing you're being
blinded by his intelligent conversation
and devastatingly handsome good looks
what
you thought to humiliate malcolm and you
end up presenting them with the perfect
wife that must sting wish me luck or boy
i don't think you'll need it
it is time to show malcolm your list i
do not think mr malcolm is the man you
think he is seems you have been
deceiving me from the beginning
love cannot be planned so carefully
it will stir things up a bit
that is part of its charm
[Music]
[Music]
you